supongamos que tenemos la suma uno menos
uno más uno menos uno más uno y así
sucesivamente hasta infinito y esto lo
podemos escribir usando la notación
sigma como la suma desde n igual a 1 n
minúscula igual a uno hasta infinito
tenemos una infinidad de términos de
veamos los términos empieza en uno
cambia menos uno y así se va alternando
esto lo podemos escribir como menos uno
elevado a la n menos uno
veamos si funciona el primer término
cuando en es igual a uno el exponente es
uno menos 10 1 a la 0 es uno cuando n es
igual a 22 menos 1 es uno menos 1 a la 1
es éste menos 1 que tenemos aquí así es
que esta es una manera de escribir esta
serie lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es determinar si esta serie converge a
un valor finito
o bien otra manera de decir esto es
existe algún valor finito que represente
el resultado de esta suma
o por el contrario podemos establecer
que esta serie diverge y la manera de
hacer esto es considerar sus sumas
parciales déjame escribir esto las sumas
parciales
de esta serie para definir estas sumas
vamos a usar un subíndice digamos n
mayúscula así es que la suma parcial la
vamos a definir como la suma desde n
igual a 1 y en vez de infinito vamos a
poner n mayúscula como límite superior
de menos 1 elevado a la n 1 veamos lo
que son estas sumas ese subíndice 1 es
igual a la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta
1 es decir tan sólo el primer término
tan solo este 1 este s sub 1 es igual a
1 veamos ahora ese sub dos este suv dos
es estos dos primeros términos 1 - 1
calculemos ahora ese sub 3 esto es 1
menos uno más uno los tres primeros
términos de la serie esto si lo
calculamos es igual a 1 menos 10 11 s
sub 20 y ese sub 1 es igual a 1
calculemos ahora ese sub
esto es igual a 1 menos 111 que otra vez
es igual a 0
de nueva cuenta la pregunta es convergen
esta suma a un valor finito te invito a
que le pongas pausa al vídeo e intente
responderla por tu cuenta
tomando en cuenta lo que hemos visto
aquí de las sumas parciales bien tenemos
que para que una serie converja para que
una serie infinita converja el límite
vamos a escribir eso por aquí si
deseamos convergencia si deseamos
convergencia esto equivale a que el
límite cuando n mayúscula tiende a
infinito de nuestras sumas parciales
esto tiene que ser igual a un número
finito vamos a ponerlo así un valor
finito y en este caso cuánto va a ser
este límite veamos si podemos escribir
esto esto va a ser ese sub n veamos si
podemos escribirla en términos generales
ya vimos que si en mayúscula es impar s
sub n es 1 y 100 en mayúscula es par s
sub n es cero esto lo podemos escribir
así
s sub n es igual a 1 si n impar 0 si n
par entonces cuál es el límite cuando n
tiende infinito cuál es el límite cuando
n tiende infinito de s sub n bien el
límite no existe está oscilando
permanentemente entre estos valores si
me das un valor más si agregas un valor
pasa de 1 a 0 si agregas otro valor pasa
de 0 a 1 de hecho no está aproximándose
a un valor finito este límite no existe
este límite vamos a ponerlo aquí este
límite no existe podríamos pensar que si
existe porque tiene valores acotados va
entre 0 y 1 pero no se aproxima a un
valor en particular a medida que n
tiende a infinito esto quiere decir
entonces que esta serie se diverge esta
serie s
bergé